yeah you know what to do welcome to this
video playing 01 so let's see what your
role is doing here doesn't you play in
place especially coffee so let's try
something else there Wow what is he up
to yes nice to do I guess
interesting whoa f5 isn't that dangerous
ok c 2 is hanging but still at looks
dangerous ok ok so he won't get
checkmate the tea anytime soon but i
like the the structure change here quite
a bit Bishop's don't do much in this
position at all how do i play here maybe
this and then 92
you
oh yes we rented lea little going on my
DS to take on g4 without getting a
backward porn backwards see Paul when
you cannot move the night away currently
check yeah now that he can do but I felt
this was fine I've got absolutely all
pawns on life squares so it's a very
healthy pawn structure and some endings
I could play for win mine appears
endings ok so here I have definitely
chances there the party I a 6v seven
days a week they look weak because they
are weak and this Bishop is not able to
attack my pawns so this is a good ending
we should a 70 b should be a to a 7 is
the immediate issue
so
[Music]
yeah I can win some bacteria now already
think I just wonder if we should be five
as an idea to this first
now this is this is ok I mean it's
definitely okay maybe we should before I
try to escape to an opposite colors
bishops end anymore okay yes this is
what he tries can do this first
before he always has the capture
unfortunately
I mean on c4 and the caption on see form
yet do I want to take I mean the
alternative is to just bring it around
he actually to e3 and now we're threaten
to take into the other ending this is
actually stronger let's do it it's got
g5
and it's got ears on yeah okay now move
the night around ya 22 g three or so not
sure where I wanted h he's got h5 and
some cases
I wonder if night on g3 actually does
much in night f5 yeah well maybe 93 move
the bishop and then night at five
looking at the h6 pawn h5 now could be a
move you cannot take it and then I go to
e form I think this is too much Wow the
thought that was will be too much to to
bear i also have Bishop to b6 and then
before stuff okay this check and then
aged 4 tall so strong let's see how to
do this here doesn't work what do I
really go we should be six and then be
form before ticks ticks ticks ticks time
I know that wins not completely certain
and hard to set wind
I think I should probably trade this I
know v6 is a weakness but and h6 is a
weakness but i think i need this for the
for this idea okay what i did not think
about this move my god takes takes takes
takes takes takes when out it twice
kinking ok way to win this Oh F no time
I have absolutely no time check and
fortunately you can always draw here why
am I was completely impractical they are
not looking at the time losing this is
of course a pretty pretty bad thing
after yeah I mean okay let's not go
there I completely didn't look at the
time absolutely did not any heroes time
up so I went over there and this doesn't
when iam unfortunately I can just take
of course oh my god that's so simple I
completely forgot about this idea i can
just take and that's over this is giving
me the porn that I want and
of course completely simple in such a
[ __ ] yeah I fell in love with that idea
that if that shocked me already i didn't
i didn't have that on the radar this is
some also not winning as i thought it
would be i saw that this wind but he
cannot take it but he doesn't have to
take it he can take here first and he
I'm inducing just take on these higher
candidate move and this is such a shame
because I was a pretty nice game to be
honest means backwards very slowly but
but methodically outplayed check and I
just just a [ __ ] you check your getting
a gig going to this ending is absolutely
render self black and black is close to
losing here he went out fairly willingly
now taking one at five I mean okay
that's entirely unplayable I mean you
simply cannot take on at five and check
taking wimps like the whole time it wins
to this cake idiotic that's so total
total madness that's total madness now
as I was saying always thinking about
this this idea with them with before and
somehow fell in love with it I never
considered to take for some reason
laughs thanks for watching